>> For a game developer, tools are the life force of your development cycle.
It's starts all the way at the beginning with the compiler that the programmers
use, all the way to the art creation tools for the artists and even notepad and
text editors for the designers. Basically, it's how we get things done. And
believe it or not, this has actually been going on for about 30 years now. So,
it really hurts my heart when we hear a lot of web game developers say that they
have to go start from scratch creating a brand-new HTML 5 game development tool.
That's simply not true. So, before you go out and actually start throwing all of
your venture capitalist money at a new studio to try and put together some HTML
5 development tools, go back and take a look at the stuff that we've been using
for the past 30 years to make really good 2D and 3D games. You'll actually find
that HTML 5 and JavaScript, in particular, is very capable of reading in data
formats from all these tool systems. So, go out and educate yourself before you
throw your money away, you'll find some good stuff out there.